[Music]
brandon is with us in lexington kentucky
starting off this hour hi brandon how
are you
doing great dave how you doing today
better than i deserve what's up
hey excellent um back at the end of
february i was in a car accident where
the airbag
was actually put in wrong airbag shot
out the front of the car the canister
flew backwards it took out my right eye
broke my neck i had severe burns it
degloved most of my face
um but that's pretty
traumatic uh yeah i think wow
um i i'm getting better you know every
day
yeah you're still healing big time
aren't you yes
i got a lot of a lot of scars and
scrapes and bruises um
but in probably ten months to a year
there will be a settlement where
conservatively it's probably around 5
million dollars
after everything's taken care of
attorneys all that
i've never had access to that kind of
money and i want to be
uh you're covering your phone i'm not
hearing you
i'm sorry um i never have access to that
kind of money was the last thing we
heard
okay yeah i've never had access for that
kind of money i want to do
things the right way as far as taxes go
um
you know take care of myself my family
and i just wanted to see what the first
steps need to be and where to go from
there if you have any advice
oh my i'm so sorry what a horrible thing
to go through
huh um
so you you have an attorney on your team
i assume
yes that is he's advising you you're
going to get the money that quickly
um they've been going about 10 to
15 months typically it's kind of open
and shut case
yeah i would think that but um wow
okay and how old are you
i'm probably 38 in about a week and a
half
what do you do for a living i've been in
the restaurant industry
serving bartending okay all right most
recently you said family
are you married in kids uh married and i
have two
wonderful step-daughters okay that are
11 and
14. okay well what you've been through
is very traumatic and very dramatic
um and so it's going to
uh and it's been you know i can't speak
to it as much as you can brandon but
i mean uh if i get a hangnail i i i cry
so i can't even imagine with the pain
and all the things you've been through
and then the permanent loss of one eye
so you know you've got some uh
emotional uh and physical
healing to do from all of that uh
it's not a good time to be making really
big
decisions uh like i hit the lotto
kind of decisions uh and so i can tell
you how to do it over the course of a
long period of time
and then you've got to implement it so
here's a whole bunch of things i'm going
to throw at you and then i want ken to
speak to your career thing
number one i want you as soon as you're
able emotionally and
physically to develop a career track i
want you to develop a career track where
you don't need this money
if you don't need this money then it's
going to work
really really really hard for you and
and you're going to be
in a position of unbelievable wealth at
the end of this story
as a result of only five million dollars
because it could let me let me give you
an example okay you're 38
if you just never touched it and
invested it
and that's not what i'm going to suggest
by the way but if that's all you did you
put it in a mutual fund
series of mutual funds and it made 10 it
would double about every seven years
so that means when you're 45 it's 10
when you're 52 it's 20.
when you're 60 it's 40
million dollars that's how important it
is that you don't
go through this money and blow it all
now we're not going to do that exact
plan
but you're going to put in place
something that gets the advantage of
that kind of thing
because to me a 65 year old with 40 or
60 million
feels a lot more exciting than a 38 year
old with 5 million
and i hope it does to you
that's where you're going if you'll go
get if you don't you know treat this
like emotionally like woohoo i hit the
lottery i know you didn't hit the
lottery i understand that you've been
through a lot of pain
and i'm not diminishing that part of it
but you see what i'm saying you don't
blow this
which is why you're calling so thank you
so here's what we're going to do
number one you put an investment person
in your corner
an investment advisor that has the heart
of a teacher
their purpose is not to do the investing
for you it's to teach you
enough that you can start to make basic
decisions on basic investing
and later on more sophisticated
investing okay
number two if you're going to do some
real estate you put a real estate person
in your corner
and if you're going to invest some of it
in real estate you would buy real estate
and that one's going to take you longer
than the other kind of investing
and you're going to pay cash for real
estate or
that's for investment purposes or you're
not going to buy do you own a home
uh no no apparently okay then we're
probably going to buy a house out of
this
but something super conservative because
every dollar we put in that house is not
doubling every seven years
right and that's where we're going to go
with this
so you begin to develop and then you get
a tax person in your corner
the same thing with the heart of a
teacher and then you get an estate
planning attorney
in your corner same thing with the heart
of a teacher
and you start to develop almost an
advisory board for
brandon incorporated and the advisory
board is an investment advisor a real
estate advisor an insurance advisor a
tax advisor
and you start to put these people in
your corner and you can find most of
them on our website i don't i'm not in
any of those businesses
i don't want anything from you i don't
want to do any of it for you
but i want you to do it and let them
have the heart of a teacher and lead you
and then i want you to move into a
career
ken yeah i curious did you have
something you always wanted to do before
the accident something you thought about
uh honestly no um i don't
all right so i've been thinking about
that i want to do something i just don't
know what i'm going to be more capable
of doing after all this is said and done
yeah that's my first thing
you need to find out from your doctor
what if any physical limitations you'll
actually have because you're still in
the healing process
so i'd start with physical limitations
and then i began to look to the heart
and
answer this question who are the people
you most want to help
what are the problem they have or maybe
a desire that they have that you would
like to be a part of that solution
when you can answer those basic
questions right there you'll begin to
see hey this is how i want to contribute
so don't think about work anymore as
just work think about it as
how am i going to contribute and begin
that process
go to kencoleman.com download the career
clarity guide and go through that
worksheet by yourself
there was some trusted people who know
you really well and it's going to begin
to give you some ideas
and then once you know your limitations
and what you need to do they get
qualified
that's how you begin that journey that
process and i agree dave if he's working
doing what he loves he's already got all
the money he needs yeah
hang on kelly's going to pick up i'm
going to put you through ramsey plus
with
financial peace university i'm going to
pay for it we don't need anything from
you we just want to help you sir
you call back as you're working through
this and i'll help you with it
and advise you as you go along